have you guys ever noticed that some  mountains kind of look like people's  faces  is it possible that these mountains  might be sleeping giants  if they were i wouldn't want to be  around to find out  naturally the mountain giants would be  massive one in iceland known as elephant  rock would be 200 meters above sea level  and this one located in canada would be  ten times bigger than the empire state  building and who knows what giants would  be hiding in mount everest they would be  at least 8 000 meters tall  if these mountains were sleeping giants  we'd know about it pretty quickly as  they probably squash us all  instead these faces on mountains are  probably just coincidences from  centuries of erosion sorry to break it  to you but even with this evidence it  still makes you wonder